the incredible finale of spider-man no  way home was almost completely different  as it was never a sure thing that marvel  was going to be able to bring back the  actors from the past spider-man films  the mysterio fallout and doctor strange  casting the spell was always part of the  plan as was the last scene with  spider-man swinging through new york but  everything else would have been  different initially the villain of the  movie was going to be craven the hunter  as the lone antagonist opposing  spider-man another version saw only toby  and andrew returning to reprise their  roles without the villains from their  respective movies returning there was  also a version where only andrew  returned and not toby as mcguire was one  of the last ones to sign a contract we  think the ending we got is perfect and  are glad everything worked out